OKAY, HERE'S THE THING.
ALL ACTORS KNOW THIS.
YOU CAN BE PRIMED TO GIVE THE
PERFORMANCE OF YOUR LIFE, BUT IF
YOU SHOW UP AND YOUR HAIR LOOKS
WRONG, ALL ANYBODY WILL BE
LOOKING AT IS YOUR HAIR.
AND IF YOU SHOW UP AND YOUR
COSTUME IS WRONG, ALL ANYBODY
WILL BE LOOKING AT IS YOUR COSTUME.
BEFORE YOU'VE EVEN SPOKEN
A LINE, YOU'RE DONE.
FOR BEST MAKEUP
AND HAIR STYLING,
FIVE DIFFERENT TEAMS
OF THREE ARE NOMINATED.
THESE ARTISTS SHARED THEIR
VARIOUS PATHS TO TONIGHT.
ONE BEGAN BY DOING
MAKEUP ON HIMSELF.
ANOTHER GOT STARTED BY
SHOWING UP ON A SET AT
3:00 A.M. TO HOLD HAIRPINS.
OTHERS BY WORKING FOR FREE ON
SMALL INDEPENDENT FILMS.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR MAKEUP
AND HAIRSTYLING.
"EMMA," MARESE LANGAN.
LAURA ALLEN, CLAUDIA STOLZE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
"HILLBILLY ELEGY,"
ERYN KRUEGER,
MATTHEW MUNGLE AND
PATRICIA DEHANEY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
"MA RAINEY'S BLACK BOTTOM,"
SERGIO LOPEZ-RIVERA.
MIA NEAL, AND JAMIKA WILSON.
[ APPLAUSE ]
"MANK," GIGI WILLIAMS,
KIMBERLEY SPITERI, AND
COLLEEN LABAFF.
[ APPLAUSE ]
"PINOCCHIO," MARK COULIER,
DALIA COLLI, AND
FRANCESCO PEGORETTI.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
"MA RAINEY'S BLACK BOTTOM,"
SERGIO LOPEZ-RIVERA,
MIA NEAL, AND JAMIKA WILSON.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
I WAS RAISED BY MY
GRANDFATHER, JAMES HOLLAND.
HE WAS AN ORIGINAL TUSKEGEE AIRMAN.
HE REPRESENTED THE U.S.
IN THE FIRST PAN AM GAMES.
HE WENT TO ARGENTINA, HE MET EVITA.
HE GRADUATED FROM NORTHWESTERN
UNIVERSITY AT A TIME THAT
THEY DID NOT ALLOW BLACKS TO STAY ON
CAMPUS, SO HE STAYED AT THE Y.M.C.A.
AND AFTER ALL OF HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
HE WENT BACK TO HIS HOMETOWN
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
A TEACHER, BUT THEY DID NOT
HIRE BLACKS IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
SO, I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO OUR
ANCESTORS WHO PUT THE WORK IN
WERE DENIED BUT NEVER GAVE UP
AND I ALSO STAND HERE, AS JAMIKA
AND I BREAK THIS GLASS CEILING
WITH SO MUCH EXCITEMENT
FOR THE FUTURE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
BECAUSE I CAN PICTURE BLACK
TRANS WOMEN STANDING UP HERE,
AND ASIAN SISTERS AND
OUR LATINA SISTERS, AND
INDIGENOUS WOMEN.
AND I KNOW THAT ONE DAY
IT WON'T BE UNUSUAL OR
GROUNDBREAKING,
IT WILL JUST BE NORMAL.
THANK YOU TO THE ACADEMY,
TO NETFLIX, TO DENZEL WASHINGTON,
TO GEORGE C. WOLFE, TO ANN ROTH
TO MISS VIOLA DAVIS
TO MATIKI ANOFF,
TO ANDREA RESNICK,
TO THE SPIRIT OF MA RAINEY.
THANK YOU.